avant de vous donner rendez vous pour le
direct de cet après midi une séquence
nostalgie jimi hendrix à la fiche ce
guitariste de légende mort il ya 23 ans
maintenant est la vedette du film qui
sort au max linder le 7 juillet jean
jacques dufour jacques gérard hommage
si vous étiez frustrés de ne pas voir
hendrix plus de cinq minutes dans le
film sur woodstock sachez que la version
longue sortira mercredi au max linder
histoire de remonter le temps et de
passer une heure avec jimmy nous étions
à l'avant-première remember camarades
c'était en 69 les babas cool criaient
peace and lobe et woodstock accueillait
quatre cent mille personnes
flash back
quand jimmy hendrix est mort en 70 yazid
manou qui s'occupe de la promotion du
film avait 5 ans c'est pourtant les fans
c'est là qu'ils prennent des claques
devant un tableau devant une fille
devant moi c'était en écoutant hendrix
après en le voyant en images et tout ça
voilà depuis je m'en suis parmis quoi ça
fait un bout de temps et bon ça reste en
moi quoi
si on aime hendrix et même si on n'aime
pas yazid est catégorique il faut voir
ce film
c'est vraiment le film à voir pour
découvrir qui était jimi hendrix parce
qu'on n'a jamais vu ça là il est
vraiment des grandioses
ça ne m'est pas au rappel de l'autre
film qui sont passées celui qui sont qui
sont sortis mais là une rixe idées et
les drames en hauteur en 69 kg top
au stop avec une nouvelle formation les
gypsy sound and numbers si on parle des
musiciens dans son temps par là encore
d'henrique donc c'est pas simplement au
niveau de la guitare c'est pour tout ce
qu'il a apporté un instrument et rock en
général donc là c'est vraiment le plus
grand musicien du 7 sept
l'année prochaine on fêtera le 25e
anniversaire de woodstock
il est loin le temps des babas cool et
des utopies